so I came across this idea the other day
I think it was Aristotle who put it out
there but it was this notion that human
beings don't care about spectacle what
they care about is ecstatic
understanding understanding
comprehension
in other words cognitive ecstasy defined
as an exhilarating neuro storm of
intense intellectual pleasure the book
the ravenous brain talks about this idea
that consciousness is obsessed with
pattern pattern is structure structure
amidst the chaos a signal in the noise
and when we find patterns when we
connect the dots we experience his
cognitive ecstasy this exhilarating
neuro storm and you know we get children
you know they're young they're learning
all the time to create new synaptic
connections they experience this
cognitive ecstasy this curiosity this
insatiable drive to understand is is is
is on fire is hermits feeling little
kids you know imagine the first time you
look at a microscope you see that Cosmo
is revealed for the first time of the
microscopic when you look from with
telescope and you all of a sudden see
the Kosmos of the macroscopic you know
perhaps the best line was Ross
Anderson's description of the
ontological awakening provided by the
Hubble Space Telescope's images of the
deep field he said through the sheer
aesthetic force of its discoveries the
Hubble distilled the complex
abstractions of astrophysics
expressions of color and light
vindicated Keith's famous couplets
beauty is truth truth beauty and the sad
part of Sir Ken Robinson says is that
losers literally grow up you know that
our educational institutions are failing
us they're not providing the context for
this curiosity to explode to continue to
emerge indefinitely instead we slowly
die and I think our goal is to create
media to create content to create spaces
that allow us to stay curious
to stay alive to awaken the Wonder
junkie in all of us to 'only shhhhh the
brave reckless God's within us all that
is my goal that is why we make shots of
awe that is why I love the TED
Conference that is why we're here to
move four moves me every day
you